rbg dies democrats panic and threaten
institutional armageddon
and trump vows to move ahead i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a right to privacy
protected at expressvpn.com
ben well me maybe you noticed this year
is crazy man i mean just chaos
in the streets everything's nuts now
we're seeing a coronavirus upsurge over
in europe obviously we have all of this
controversy
over the supreme court the election is
coming up who knows what's coming around
the corner and this is why your
investment portfolio should be
diversified at least a little bit
into precious metals imagine if you had
listened to me back in 2016 when i told
you to invest just a little bit
in gold back then gold was 1300 an ounce
now it is hovering around
historic highs and as i've been saying
this year is going to be nuts and it's
not going to stop
being nuts if you haven't reached out to
birch gold to diversify at least part of
your ira or 401k into a precious metals
high array or just purchase some
physical
gold or silver from them go ahead and do
it today text ben 247 4747 get a free
information kit on protecting your
savings
with gold listen i have some gold in my
portfolio i trust the folks over at
birch school they've got an a plus
rating with the better business bureau
countless five star reviews talk to them
they are extremely knowledgeable they
can help you
preserve your savings text ben 247 47 47
open a precious metals ira today or just
purchase some physical precious metals
again text ben
247 47 47 i've known the folks at birch
gold for a very long time and i've been
urging you to invest for a very long
time at least a little bit diversify
just a little bit into precious metals
get started by texting ben
to 47 47 47 to get started
okay so right before rosh hashanah
begins
i get the information that ruth bitter
ginsburg
the longtime supreme court justice first
appointed in 1993
a famous feminist voice uh has passed
away and
in judaism the first thing you always
say is met blessed is the true
a true judge so we say that obviously
because
death comes to us all whether we are you
know on the side of the righteous or
whether we are not on the side of the
righteous
ruth bader ginsburg for all of our
disagreements and we had many of them
obviously i disagree with her politics
thoroughly and profoundly she devoted
decades of her life to public service
she was responsible for some things that
i think everyone can agree with
including the forwarding of women's
rights in the workplace
a lot of those things are very good and
uh her passage
should be met with national mourning of
course this of course however
raises the greatest i think
constitutional crisis
that i've seen in modern american
history not because of what the
republicans are going to do fill the
seat but because of what democrats are
threatening
to do now let's be real about this from
the very beginning ruth bader ginsburg
should have stepped
down when barack obama was president now
apparently her dying wish
was that her seat not be filled and
democrats are making a big deal out of
this
there is no constitutional provision
that allows a justice as their dying
wish to pick their successor
in communist countries judges pick their
successors that is not what happens in a
free republic in a free republic
however the process works is how the
process works imagine if justice antonin
scalia had left a note by his bedside
table before he had a heart attack and
died
saying my dying wish is that the supreme
court overturned roe versus wade
do you think there would have been five
seconds of consideration over his dying
wish that is not how this works
you do not get to will your supreme
court seats to somebody else because it
is not in fact your supreme court seat
it is a seat that pre-exists you and
will exist long after you
just as donald trump doesn't get to will
the presidency of the united states to
whoever he wants to be his successor
rbg does not get to will her seat to
anybody else so her dying wishes have
absolutely no constitutional value we
all know this by the way i mean she was
holding on tenaciously to that supreme
court seat she didn't want to step down
because she didn't want
trump to fill the seat and it's patently
obvious that the reason that she didn't
step down
earlier is because she thought hillary
clinton was going to win okay she should
have stepped down
in 2010. remember she was diagnosed with
pancreatic cancer back in 2009
she was 87 years old when she died so
that means she was 76 years old when she
was diagnosed diagnosed with pancreatic
cancer now typically
pancreatic cancer unfortunately has a
very high kill rate
and she stayed on the court for another
11 years after her original diagnosis
with pancreatic cancer again
when barack obama was president she
could have stepped down any time in
there
and she didn't step down in 2016 because
she figured that
she was going to be on the court while
hillary clinton was president
bill clinton has said as much right bill
clinton was asked by margaret brennan
about this
margaret brennan said ginsburg
reportedly told her friends she had
intended to retire
under what she expected to be a hillary
clinton presidency did you ever talk to
her about that
do you know who she envisioned taking
her place and clinton said no i mean i
knew i hoped
hillary would be elected in 2016 i
thought she would and hoped she'd have
some time because she wanted to leave
the court while she was still at full
steam
she wanted to leave the court with
someone who she thought was not an
ideologue someone who was too far to the
right but i i don't think she
necessarily had a preferred candidate
i think she trusted hillary to make a
good decision it was perfectly obvious
that she was sticking around because she
thought hillary was going to win then
trump won
and then it became basically a race
against the clock for ruth bader
ginsburg
and you could see this in the way that
the democratic party infrastructure
mobilized around her she became the
notorious rbg
right she moved from being just like a
normal left-wing supreme court justice
to being this iconic figure because
the idea was that she stood between the
democrats and doom she stood between the
democrats
and armageddon and here's the thing
this demonstrates full scale how the
democrats think of the supreme court
which is why honestly they should never
be picking supreme court justices
so as we'll see we're going to discuss a
little bit later on the so-called
mcconnell doctrine from back in 2016
what he actually said
was he saying that in the final year of
a presidency that the president should
not select or that his selection should
not be confirmed no he didn't say that
he never said that what he said instead
was that if the senate was controlled by
a different party than the president the
senate had no obligation to move forward
with a nomination if they were of a
different party than the president until
the american public had sounded off on
what they wanted to be the final
combination of factors leading to the
selection
of the supreme court justice but in the
final year of a presidency
we've had some 29 selections by
presidents it's perfectly normal for a
president
to select the the person to fill a
supreme court seat
in 17 of those cases the president
or in 17 yeah 17 of those cases the
president and senate have been
controlled by the same party
and in 15 of those 17 cases that person
has been confirmed this is something
senator ted cruz pointed out over the
weekend this is of course exactly
historically correct
29 times there has been a vacancy in a
presidential election year
now presidents have made nominations all
29 times
when the senate has been of the same
party of the president a vacancy occurs
in an election year
of the 29 times those are 19 of them of
those 19 the senate has
confirmed those nominees 17 times so if
the parties are the same
the senate confirms the nominee when the
parties are different that's happened 10
times merrick garland was one of them
of those 10 the senate has confirmed the
nominees
only twice okay it is very
uncontroversial constitutionally
speaking the president gets to fill the
seat
and then the senate gets to decide
whether they decide to go up or down on
it
i thought that mcconnell you can go back
and listen to my show at the time i
thought mcconnell in 2016 was being too
cute by half on the merrick garland
thing
by saying well you know it's the last
year of the presidency we'll wait until
the election is decided to me this is a
very simple thing
you should not vote for any nominee who
you feel is not going to interpret the
constitution properly
i don't care whether it is the first
year of barack obama's term and he is
selecting sonia sotomayor or elena kagan
or whether it is the last year of barack
obama's term and he is selecting
merrick garland it makes no difference
to me whatsoever in any way
the bottom line is this the
constitutional role of the supreme court
is to interpret the constitution
properly
the democrats have used the supreme
court to enact policy
from the bench for decades republicans
have gone along with this
out of some sense of nostalgia for a
time when the supreme court was far less
political but the democrats made this
whole thing political way back in the
80s this all started with bork and we've
seen its culmination
in the attempt to go after justice
kavanaugh with false charges of gang
rape and such
with ridiculous charges that he was
involved in a boofing when he was 17
years old
the democrats made this political
they've decided that the supreme court
is merely another political tool in
their arsenal
they have no institutional respect for
the supreme court the supreme court is
not something they care about
and this is something i talk about in my
book how to destroy america in three
easy steps
for democrats unfortunately it has
become the case that the institutions of
the united states government are an
obstacle to them
and when they are an obstacle they seek
to destroy the obstacle this is why over
the past several years since trump was
elected
they've talked about abolishing the
electoral college they've talked about
completely redoing the senate or
abolishing the senate all together
they are now talking about packing the
supreme court they were talking about
that a year ago
people pete blue judge said openly in
the middle of this race
that he was willing to pack the supreme
court and this became a question
on the debate stage as to whether people
were going to pack the supreme court
democrats have nothing but scorn for the
institutional checks and balances
of the government of the united states
because they believe that those
institutional checks and balances are an
obstacle to complete rule from above it
has been true for a very long time
now even ruth bader ginsburg was not
opportunist enough to believe that
packing the court was a good idea
right ruth bader ginsburg all the way
back in 2016 i believe
was specifically asked about packing the
court and here is what she said at the
time
i have heard that there are some people
on the democratic side who would like to
increase the number of judges i think
that was a bad idea when president
franklin delano roosevelt
tried to pack the court of anything
would make the court appear
partisan it would be that one side
saying
when we're in power was going to enlarge
the number
of judges so we will have more people
who will
vote the way we want them to okay so
even ruth better ginsburg recognized the
threat to the institutions
the old school liberals however are no
longer in control of the democratic
party they don't believe in the
institutions of the constitution
they believe in overthrowing them and
honestly this has a long legacy inside
of the democratic party woodrow wilson
sought to overthrow
the checks and balances of the
constitution by radically expanding the
executive branch
and overthrowing all checks and balances
taking all the powers of the legislature
and placing them inside the executive
you saw fdr's attempt to pack the court
back in the 1930s this led to the
supreme court changing a lot of its
doctrine in what was called the switch
in time that saved nine
meaning that it saved nine seats on the
supreme court as opposed to 13 seats on
the supreme court because fdr was
threatening to pack the court
institutions for the democratic party
are of no interest
they don't like the structural
constitution because they don't like the
fundamental philosophy underlying the
structural constitution which is that of
limited government
and checks and balances that protect
your rights the constitution was written
for a very specific purpose
that purpose was to protect the
principles of the declaration of
independence and the basic idea
was that a government that is unitary in
nature a government that has
unified power at the top and no checks
and balances either hierarchically with
the state
or horizontally between the branches was
going to infringe upon your rights
democrats believe the government should
infringe upon your rights because your
rights come from government and a
government big enough to give you what
you want is a government that is also
big enough to take away what you have
democrats have always seen these
institutional checks and balances
as a problem so why in the world would
you let democrats appoint people to the
supreme court who are promptly going to
use the supreme court as another
political body
the supreme court's original designation
was to interpret the constitution of the
united states
democrats don't like the constitution of
the united states and have appointed
justices who similarly do not like the
constitution of the united states and
see it as an obstacle to what they
attempt to do
they see the constitution as a bit of
poetry that they can interpret
however they see fit from the obamacare
cases to roe versus wade democratic
justices never miss they never miss
because they are politically motivated
they do not bother reading the
constitution
the way that you can tell whether a
justice reads the constitution or does
not read the constitution
is whether that justice always votes
with your political priors or
whether that justice sometimes votes
against your political priors based on
the text of a law before them
democrats get what they want from their
justices no question which is a good
indicator as to how they see the court
and you have to understand all this
because that is what is undergirding the
battle that we are currently undergoing
the battle that is about to break upon
us is one that is
honestly country shattering in nature
and it's not because of anything trump
or the republicans is about to do
as we're about to discuss what democrats
are threatening to do violate the
structural integrity of the constitution
in massive new ways
violate every norm break institutions of
the constitution
what they're threatening to do can in
fact split the country apart
and they're using this as blackmail in
order to prevent republicans from
fulfilling their constitutional duty
to fill that seat and so that they can
pack the court
unofficially with another member of the
hard left who will then rule in favor of
all of their democratic
political strategies in order to
understand that you have to understand
how democrats see the court
the democrats do not see the court as an
expositor of the constitution
they see the court as a second
legislature this is why the worship for
rbg
you know conservatives we really like
clarence thomas i'm a huge clarence
thomas fan we really like justice scalia
a lot but there was never the sort of
worshipful
insanity you see for democrats and rbg
rbg was was a near idol for many
democrats in the same way the
democrats have a tendency to buy vote of
candles of robert mueller if he's going
to stop trump or something
they they were worshipful toward rbg
again they were calling her the
notorious rpg
she was an octogenarian liberal justice
who spends her life in the law
and they were treating her as the
notorious rbg because she was slaying
queen
because for the democrats when it comes
to the constitution the constitution is
secondary
political priority is primary and you
can see this in the reaction to rbg's
death
so just to take an example i mean i
think this is the it of the democratic
party right here there is a video going
around online
over the weekend of a liberal woman
having a screaming meltdown over the
death of rbg
now can we be clear about something the
if trump fills this seat and he fills it
with amy coney barrett
or if he fills it with a justice from
florida and barbara lagoa
if he if he fills that seat the chances
of roe versus wade being overturned
are nearly zero i say nearly zero only
because
i hedge my bets a little bit they're
basically zero row versus weight is not
going to be overturned
there are not five votes for it even if
even if you
put someone on the court right now who
vowed to overturn roe versus wade
there's still not five votes for it
kavanaugh's not going to vote to
overturn roe versus wade alito
i doubt he's going to vote to overturn
roe versus wade and i don't think
gorsuch is going to vote to overturn roe
vs wade i think legit
you have one vote to overturn roe vs
wade on the supreme court right now and
it's clarence thomas
so all of the panic the insane panic you
see from democrats
over this seat is because what they want
the supreme court to be
is a green light for every democratic
priority and they are afraid
of anyone appointed to the court who
will in any way provide some sort of
speed bump
in their pursuit of power that's all
this is okay so here is this liberal
crazy lady screaming about rbg
holy you guys i'm driving your
car but i just got a notification that
ruth bader ginsburg died
could this year get any worst
ruth you just had to make it to 2021.
okay so why you would film this and then
put it online except that this does
channel
a lot of what democrats are feeling
because for them the supreme court is a
tool of power
it was never supposed to be just another
member of the triumvirate of checks and
balances executive
legislative and judicial this is
unreasonable behavior it is not
reasonable behavior
nobody on the republican side reacted
this way when sonia sotomay mayor's
filled the seat if merrick garland had
been confirmed by the republican senate
people would have been upset would have
been screaming fits like this i have
serious serious doubts
okay the the attempt to turn the supreme
court into just another avenue of power
has been the legacy of the democratic
party for a very long time which is why
they should not be in charge of
selecting justices under nearly any
circumstances
okay we're going to get to more of this
in just one second as we'll see
is their belief that the supreme court
as an institution of power must be held
by democrats and therefore
all institutions must be broken to
achieve power we'll get to that in one
second first
let's talk about the fact very often you
want to know who is coming to your door
so i have kids at home and i've got a
wife at home and these days everybody's
at home
and you want to know who's coming your
door so let's say that i am out of my
house
and somebody rings the doorbell well
very often when somebody is going to rob
your house they ring the doorbell to
make sure that you are not home first
well now i can pick up and i can tell
exactly
who it is or i can use the ring devices
on my property to keep track of my kids
who are constantly attempting to kill
themselves because this is what small
children do whatever you call home
ring has everything you need to protect
it see and speak to whoever is at your
door from anywhere with video doorbells
keep an eye on every corner of your
house with easy to install indoor and
outdoor cams protect your whole home
with ring alarm a powerful affordable
whole home security system
you can easily install yourself you know
i've had significant security worries
for a long time
ring has alleviated those worries i mean
i
i'm a person who needs six hundred
thousand dollars of security just to go
to berkeley so when i say that i trust
ring to keep my property safe
trust you me that means that i trust
ring get a special offer on the ring
welcome kid at ring.com
it comes with rings video doorbell 3 and
chime pro the perfect way to start your
ring experience plus
free two-day shipping go to ring.com
that is ring.com
okay so it's not just that screaming
lady who reacts this way democrats
reacted this way so aoc she's talking
about
what is on the line here and this is so
ridiculous
i mean i'm sorry it's absolutely
ridiculous here is aoc explaining what
is on the line for democrats because
they believe the supreme court is just
supposed to be a second democratic
legislature doing what they want
they don't actually understand what the
supreme court does so you're going to
hear her say for example our
reproductive
rights are on the line here no they
really are not there are legislators all
across the country
like unless you forget if roe vs wade
were overturned which it will not be
to my great chagrin and rage if roe
versus wade we're overturned
all that would mean is that new york and
massachusetts and california and
connecticut
and every other liberal state would all
continue to have abortion on demand
because it would just evolve all
authority back to the state level it
would not actually create a new federal
rule against abortion
but here is aoc again they just want
what they want from the supreme court
if they don't get it they're gonna
they're gonna scream and break things
it's extraordinarily important that we
understand the stakes
of this vacancy our reproductive rights
are on the line our labor rights are on
the line
our right to health care is on
the line labor and union protections
are on the line our climate is
on the line okay so again
for them everything is on the line
because if they don't have the super
legislature that is going to cram down
what they want
they're going to break all of the things
amy klobuchar who's supposed to be a
moderate she said the same thing she
said our democracy is at stake here
our democracy is not at stake if you
believe that our democracy was hanging
by the slender threat of an 87 year old
woman
with pancreatic cancer if you believe
that our democracy
was really that thin the problem is not
rbg dying the problem is that the
country is fundamentally broken
but here's klobuchar saying exactly that
when the my republican colleagues and
some of them have already
come out and said the right thing
because they understand what's at stake
here
that you they don't want to join in with
the president who is lying and lying and
lying
in terms of how he's going to handle a
supreme court nomination
literally our democracy is at stake and
i think michelle obama
said it best when she said your life
depends on it so you better vote
this is insane your life does not depend
on your vote you're not going to die if
you vote for a democrat and you're not
going to die if you vote for republican
and you're not going to die
if amy coney barrett joins the supreme
court i mean you might die but it's
going to have nothing to do with any of
those things
chuck schumer says the same thing again
for for the democrats every institution
is an institutional club that can be
wielded for power and if we can't wield
it we're gonna break it it is that
simple
right this is a weapon and if i can't
wield the weapon i'm gonna break the
weapon
that's what chuck schumer is saying here
we're here to protect the rights
of our globe and the people who live on
it so that climate
is protected a court
with a kind of nominee president trump
will choose will undo
all of that okay can i just point out
there is no constitutional right for the
globe in the constitution
okay the the earth you know a big ball
of matter it does not actually have
rights under the constitution of the
united states because it's a giant
inanimate object
floating through space also it is not
the job of the supreme court to make
global warming policy
it is the job of the supreme court to
interpret whether in fact an executive
agency is acting in accordance with
legislative policy
or whether that legislative policy
actually violates the tenants of the
constitution
it isn't it is your job you're the
senate minority leader it's your job to
make policy you think protect
the globe and global warming that's not
the job of the supreme court
what he's really talking about there is
he wants the supreme court to read it
into the clean air act
that carbon emissions can be considered
a pollutant which of course was never
considered under the clean air act
but this is exactly how democrats think
about the court the court is just a tool
of power to hammer
and so this leads to tremendous levels
of dishonesty aoc said
it i can't believe that mitch mcconnell
won't honor rbg's last wish
again well what does she think we live
in a monarchy
that's not the way this works honor
rbg's last wish
i mean first of all i hope that honestly
i hope that rbg had other wishes besides
that for her last wish i hope that that
is a bit of a
of a a bit of exaggerated rhetoric for
purposes of the political moment from
the family
i hope that she was thinking about other
things on her deathbed because i
wouldn't want to be thinking about
politics as i died right that just seems
like an unpleasant way to go but here is
aoc
here's aoc saying that the republicans
are bad because they won't honor rbg's
last wish
well good news i guess when clarence
thomas goes you know hopefully in 25
years or something when clarence thomas
goes
he should wish for a complete reversion
to the constitutional order
and structure that the founders intended
meaning that we wipe away several
million federal jobs and we'll just
honor his last wish because that's what
that's what
i didn't realize there was that
constitutional provision last with wish
of a dying justice
must be must be implemented by the
legislature who knew who knew
tonight mitch mcconnell publicly
the night that she the night of her
passing he couldn't wait
24 hours issued a statement
saying that he was going to
give trump a vote in violation of of her
dying wish
people can say how appalling people
could say this is horrible
etc but we know who this man is
we know who this man is this is a man
who does not care about a dying woman's
final wish
yeah what is this i'm sorry that's
absurd it's absurd
it's an absurdity of the highest order
that the senate should be sitting there
going
yes but what are they writing their will
okay this isn't she can't will the seat
she doesn't own the seat
but when you believe that the democrats
ought to control
the auspices of power and they can will
that power to other people
this is what you get and so democrats
have said nothing is off the table
democrats have said nothing is off the
table they
both chuck schumer and and blumenthal
senator blumenthal from connecticut
richard blumenthal
they've both said nothing is off the
table according to cnn's senior
congressional correspondent
raju he reported that schumer told
democrats on a call let me be clear
if leader mcconnell and senate
republicans move forward with this
nothing is off the table for next year
nothing is off the table 20 minutes
later richard blumenthal made the same
threat he tweeted if republicans
recklessly and reprehensibly force a
supreme court vote
before the election nothing is off the
table
so what do they mean by nothing is off
the table what they mean by nothing is
off the table
is that they will think about packing
the court they will thinking about
they will think about using impeachment
axios reports today
that they are talking about adding
supreme court justices eliminating the
filibuster
and statehood for dc and puerto rico now
there's only one problem
as uh as mitch mcconnell's spokesperson
said
every single threat they are currently
making they already made four months ago
they already shot the hostage
okay if this is a hostage negotiation
they already shot the hostage also
i have a basic rule of constitutional
jurisprudence do not negotiate with
constitutional terrorists if people are
threatening to break every institution
of government unless you give them what
they want
why would you then give them power over
that government that makes no sense at
all
we'll get to this in just one second
first
let's talk about the fact that you
really don't want to be spending all of
your business time and money on legal
you can really rack up those huge legal
bills super easily if you're using a law
firm
and this is why instead you should be
using legalzoom i've been using
legalzoom since long before they're a
sponsor
on this program if you need legal help
for your challenges legalzoom has proven
to be a reliable resource for families
and business owners everywhere
during these unprecedented times
legalzoom has been dedicated to helping
you with the right solutions for more
than 19 years
whether you need a will or a living
trust to protect your family or if you
need help starting a business the right
way with a dba llc nonprofit or more
legalzoom can help you do it it's easy
to get started online and if you need
guidance their network of attorneys can
provide legal advice to ensure you're
making the right choices
since legalzoom is into law firm you
won't have to leave your home and you
won't get charged
by the hour we've been using legalzoom
here at the daily wire offices and again
i've used legalzoom for literally years
do wills do trust to do simple contracts
to do llc formation visit legalzoom.com
today to take care of some important
things you need to get done that's
legalzoom.com and again they now have
this giant network of attorneys that can
give you legal advice and help you
through the process visit legalzoom.com
today save yourself time
save yourself money don't go bankrupt on
your law expenses visit legalzoom.com
today so democrats are threatening to
break everything
so according to axios adding supreme
court justices eliminating the senate 60
vote threshold 10 filibusters and
statehood for dc and puerto rico
if he holds vote in 2020 will pack the
court in 2021 said representative joe
kennedy of massachusetts
according to axios democrats are not
optimistic about blocking the nominee
but they have many ways of retaliating
if they win senate control and are
licking their chops about real movement
and ideas that have been
pushed futilely for decades for instance
the constitution does not fix the number
of justices which could be changed by an
act of congress and the president's
signature
according to the national constitution
center
apparently again schumer has already
said
that he would think about packing the
court house judiciary chair jerry nadler
tweeted yesterday if senator mcconnell
and senate gop were to force through a
nominee during the lame duck session
before a new senate and president can
take office then the incoming senate
should immediately move to expand the
supreme court
former obama attorney general eric
holder who's been championed as captain
abide by the law which was always absurd
he backed that idea yesterday
as well also we already know that
democrats have talked about eliminating
the filibuster remember that president
obama who used the filibuster
many many times robustly he used the
filibuster during the during his senate
career
he called the filibuster rule a jim crow
relic remember democrats have used that
jim crow relic several times this year
to stymie republican legislation
including a coronavirus relief bill as
well as a police reform bill
they've also talked about adding dc and
adding puerto rico as states in the
assumption that both of those will will
then
vote democrat which would add four
democratic senators and completely skew
the balance of power
in the senate of the united states that
would be a complete violation of
institutional norms going back all the
way to the beginning of the republic
if there were two sides in america
whatever those sides were pro-slavery
anti-slavery democratic versus
republican
the basic rule was whatever the two
sides were if you were going to add
states you added them two at a time one
for one side one for the ever
one for the other so you didn't violate
the constitutional structure and create
an impetus for states to believe that
they were being jobs and then leave the
union
democrats are talking about pushing
incredibly incredibly hard
brian fallon executive director of
demand justice
and a former top schumer aide said one
opposed trump's nominee prior to the
election invoking the gop's own rule
from 2016 as we'll say in a second that
was not in fact the gop rule from 2016.
the gop rule was never at least not
according as mitch mcconnell articulated
it it was never
a president cannot have his nominee
confirmed in the final year of his term
it was
if the president is of a different party
from the senate he cannot guarantee that
his nominee will be confirmed
which again historically happens to be
true you say step two defeat trump on
november third
three keep seed open until biden takes
office four if gop rams trump picked
through anyway add seats to the core
this is the play there is no other play
okay erwin tremorinsky who is a long
time
democratic theorist from usc
he has a piece out today in the in the
la times openly calling
for the democrats to pack the court he
says that this is the secret weapon
they should they should pack the court
asap
he says the democrats have a few cards
to play at a crucial moment for our
democracy the stakes are enormous
last term with ginsberg on the bench the
court handed down surprising five-four
decisions to protect individual rights
including a decision to strike down
louisiana's restrictive abortion law and
to invalidate trump's rescission
of daca if ginsberg is replaced the
chance of such rulings will evaporate
okay let's be frank about this again
even if that happened all that would
happen is that there would be additional
abortion restrictions in red states
there would not be abortion restrictions
in blue states that would continue
as is and daca by the way that was a bad
decision
one way for democrats to make clues
according to trumarinsky one way for
democrats to make clear they will not
tolerate republicans trying to fill this
seat in advance of the election would be
for them to pledge that if they take the
white house and senate in november they
will increase the size of the supreme
court to 13 justices
the number of justices on the court is
set by federal law not the constitution
since its beginning it has ranged from
having between five and ten members
since the 1860s it has remained
at nine so now he says we should pack
the court
okay meanwhile joe felipe over at the
washington post saying exactly the same
thing if mcconnell pushes through a
nominee president biden should pack the
court
republicans have put party over
principle biden can do something about
it
okay first of all it's not putting party
over principle to vote
for a nominee that a president of your
party nominated that is like the way
things are generally done
it's only the stupidity of republicans
in confirming a bunch of
democratic hacks to the supreme court
that has led to this current
belief that republicans have an
obligation to vote on merrick garland
or should not vote on the republican
nominee by the way it's fun to watch
everybody rush to the other side right
so you have a bunch of people who in
2016 were like yeah we don't have to
vote on merrick garland and democrats
like you have to vote on merrick garland
you must vote on merrick garland and now
it's four years later like you must
never vote
on amy coney barrett you must never do
it like the switch in time is pretty
incredible
people just rushing side to side
frantically as the titanic goes down
according to joe felipe for liberals
ruth bader ginsburg's death brings shock
that nikon is gone that she didn't make
it
until the next presidency and terror
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
who in 2016 blocked president barack
obama from filling the supreme court
seat vacated about nine months before
the presidential election
says he will permit trump to fill one
left empty s
to fill one left empty less than two
months before this year's election
democrats have only one play here if
trump and mcconnell jamming to point he
through
it is not enough for democrats to raise
hell about the hypocrisy the duplicity
it's not enough to target every
republican senator who goes along it's
not enough to have voters bombard the
republican senator's offices with phone
calls and protests
because those things have been happening
for four years and none of them have
persuaded the gop
to put stability of the country or
obligations of office ahead
of that party's thirst for power so
democrats should threaten to pack the
court
and if mcconnell pushes through a new
justice and joe biden wins they should
follow through
so democrats are threatening to break
the institutions
that's not the only institution they are
threatening to break by the way they are
also
threatening to use impeachment and so
last i checked impeachment was for high
crimes or misdemeanors
now listen you can impeach for any
reason it is perfectly constitutional to
impeach for any reason under the sun but
there has been a general rule that the
very least you have to have the slender
read
of some basis for an impeachment
democrats are now saying what if we just
impeached rando mcface over here to hold
up the senate
the senate's business so they can't
actually confirm a justice
aoc said this she says what if we just
impeach trump or bar or like
bob you know the janitor over at the
white house let's impeach that guy
because that'll hold up the senate here
was aoc the fact that aoc and schumer
did a joint presser
about this is pretty incredible
would you be in support of potentially
reviewing costs
or the president well you know i think
um i i believe that
certainly there has been an enormous
amount of law breaking in the trump
administration
we we must consider again all of the
tools available to our disposal
and that all of all of these options
should be entertained and on the table
okay so there it is and then nancy
pelosi asked about this
and uh she said that we have arrows in
our quiver many many arrows in our
quiver it was fun i mean george
stephanopoulos
who has led a life of attempting to
basically spout democratic talking
points through his questions you'll
recall back in 2012
when he randomly asked in the middle of
a republican debate whether mitt romney
was going to get rid of contraceptives
and everybody's like what in the hell is
he talking about and that immediately
within a week
turned into the war on women narrative
pushed by the democratic party well here
is george stephanopoulos who obviously
had some ideas planted with him i think
it's pretty obvious here he plans the
idea of nancy pelosi supposedly of
impeachment
here he is saying what if we just
impeach trump to you know hold up the
business of the senate
some have mentioned the possibility if
they try to push through a nominee in a
lame duck session
that that you in this the house could
move to impeach
president president trump or attorney
general barr as a way of stalling and
preventing the senate from acting
on this nomination well we have our
options we have arrows
in our quiver that i'm not about to
discuss right now
but the fact is we have a big challenge
in our country
okay worth noting that pelosi then
completely lost her train of thought in
the middle of the conversation
and literally restarted the interview so
one of the great things about our
current republic
is that everybody is geriatric and
senile who is currently in a position of
power or running for a position of power
when the young buck
is chuck schumer you know you're in
trouble here's nancy pelosi completely
losing her train of thought and nearly
healing over
10 states as i said on friday i started
there early for
voting the day that we launched ruth
bader ginsburg
but to be clear you're not taking any
arrows out of your quiver you're not
ruling anything out
good morning sunday morning
the uh we have a responsibility
wow it's it's weird when those gears get
stuck there for just a second the botox
infuses the brain so
all good stuff happening in the country
here's the bottom line for a lot of this
what's happening right now is the
democrats are threatening to destroy
institutions
and the media are telling trump that
he's destroying institutions by doing
exactly what the constitution says the
president is supposed to do
and the mcconnell is destroying
institutions by doing exactly what the
senate
is supposed to do you can't negotiate
with political terrorists it is
political terrorism to threaten to burn
down every institution of government
unless you get your way
it's what my son does when he is fussing
and he decides to lie on the floor and
scream and shout
he does not get what he wants he goes to
his room there is no
in fact it is significantly more
important that republicans now put
through a justice
simply to make the point that democrats
cannot threaten to burn down
every institution of constitutional
government because they don't like the
outcome of the system
here's the reality of the situation roe
vs wade is not gonna be overturned in
all likelihood
two ruth bader ginsburg should have
stepped down ten years ago
if you don't like how this went that is
only on the democrats
three if democrats gain power
undoubtedly they will have some
opportunities to pick supreme court
justices
as well this is how the system works but
we have now seen from the democrats
that they have no respect for any of the
institutional architecture of the
constitution we've been seeing this
throughout
for all the talk about trump violating
institutional norms because trump says
vulgar things and boorish things and
he's blunt and he says all this stuff
the fact is democrats trotted out stacy
abrams at the dnc claiming she was
governor of georgia after losing by 50
000 votes
i don't want to hear about institutional
norms when your party is openly
threatening
to pack the court impeach people for no
reason just to hold up the process
add states willy-nilly through simple
majority vote and break
whatever balance there is in the united
states and here is the predictable
result of this let's say that the
democrats
went forward with all of this let's say
that the democrats really went for it
let's say that they did all of this
let's say the republicans appoint
amy coney barrett they confirm emmy
coney barrett joe biden comes in
and then he says we're adding four
supreme court justices and puerto rico
dc and guam all become states right we
now have six new senators and they are
all democrats and that's what we're
doing let's say that happens how long do
you think the country lasts after that
do you think that texas florida georgia
mississippi
any of those states are going to abide
by federal dictates
coming down from a perverted form of
constitutional government nobody
consented to
do you think that they're going to abide
by a constitutional decision coming from
a court of 13 packed by democrats
do you think that states are simply
going to remain as they become
minorities in a government to which they
did not consent do you think that that
is going to happen or do you think we
are going to come to a true
constitutional impasse it is not the
appointment of the justice that is a
constitutional impasse it is the
violation of the system itself that is
the constitutional impasse
republicans cannot give into this
because if you are living with the sword
of damocles hanging over your head every
moment that oh if we don't give
democrats what they want guys
you know next time they get power
they're going to kill the filibuster add
states destroy the supreme court
well then guess what we do not have a
social compact anymore so maybe
democrats want to make clear we don't
have a social compact anymore
but if they do it's on them if they do
it's on them
and guess what if a state says if texas
says we are not a let's say that a
democratic senate passes
a gun confiscation measure that violates
the second amendment and a packed
democratic supreme court then says you
know what
second amendment no longer is in the
constitution go ahead
do what you want you think texas is
going to abide by that
they won't and they should not okay
because the bottom line is whoever
breaks the system
is now responsible for the breaking of
the system appointing a justice and
confirming injustice
is not breaking the system we're gonna
get to more of this
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact
that you can still in these dark and
difficult times you can still do
something really really meaningful i'm
talking about taking
a family memory or taking a picture of
one of your favorite people or situation
and turning it into a beautiful portrait
you can hang above your mantelpiece so
in my house
in my magnificent home i have a
beautiful portrait of me
my wife and two of our three children
which means it's time for us to go back
to paint your life
and now get a picture of all of us
including my tiny little baby who is the
very cutest baby in the entire world
we need a portrait of her that's why
we're going to head on over to
paintyourlife.com
and get a professional hand-painted
portrait created from any photo at a
truly affordable price
choose from a team of world-class
artists work with them until every
detail is perfect
user-friendly platform that lets you
order a custom-made hand-painted
portrait
in less than five minutes it's a quick
and easy process you get a hand-painted
portrait in about three weeks
it's meaningful it's personal it can be
cherished forever at paintyourlife.com
there's no risk if you don't love the
painting
your money is refunded guaranteed right
now is a limited time offer you get
twenty percent off your painting that is
correct
twenty percent off and free shipping to
get this special offer text the word ben
to sixty four thousand that is ben to
sixty four thousand text ben to 64 000
right now paint your life celebrate the
moments that matter most
alrighty you are listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
so democrats are now engaged in open
constitutional blackmail we're going to
impeach people for no reason we're going
to pack the court we're going to add
states we're going to kill the
filibuster we're going to destroy every
institution of government because
we didn't get our way that's the short
version of this
naturally the media are proclaiming that
republicans are violating constitutional
norms
by nominating and confirming injustice
as we've already discussed this is not
the case
so president trump came out immediately
and he said he was at a rally when he
found out about this and then he was
told about it
on the way on the way back to his plane
on the tarmac he said some nice words
about rbg then over the weekend he did
another rally in north carolina and he
said i'm going to nominate a woman this
week
i could see most likely it would be a
woman yeah i think i could say that it
would be
a woman i would if somebody were to ask
me now
i would say that a woman would be
in first place yes we'll be making a
decision i think the process
can go very very fast i'll be making my
choice soon
and when the choice is made i'll be
sending it over to mitch in the senate
and they will do what they have to do i
think the choice will be next week
okay so this of course sets the world a
flame mitch mcconnell said immediately
after this that he was going to fill the
seat
he came out very quickly he said we're
not going to sit by and not fill the
seat he said president trump's nominee
will receive a vote on the floor of the
united states
senate senate majority whip john thune
who's the number two he said i believe
americans sent a republican president
and republican senate to washington
to ensure we have an impartial judiciary
that upholds the constitution in the
rule of law
we will fulfill our obligation to them
as leader mcconnell has said president
trump's supreme court nominee will
receive a vote on the floor
of the united states senate lisa
murkowski
and uh susan collins immediately said no
they said they're not going to vote
on any nominee that comes forward this
year that is not a shock it's not a
shock that murkowski is doing that
that's very murkowski
it's not really a shock that collins is
doing that either collins had expressed
hesitance at voting this way in the
final year of trump's term and she's an
extremely competitive race
in maine right now this basically leaves
two senators who are up for grabs so
republicans can lose three and then have
pence break the tie
so there is a time limit on this okay in
arizona
democrat mark kelly is running against
gop senator martha mcsally
the winner would be sworn in probably
november 30th depending on
if she is replaced if that happens then
the republicans lose a vote
right so basically trump has to get this
done now one of the questions is is he
gonna try and get this done now try to
do it in a lame duck session
he should try and do it now he should
try to get it done right now and let the
democrats have their hearings
let them try and slime whoever the
republican nominee is kavanaugh style
which they absolutely will do that's
already begun as we'll talk
about in just a second okay so right now
republicans can lose three but not four
so they've already lost collins very
lost markowski that means they can
afford to lose one more but not two
right so grassley senator chuck grassley
from iowa he had suggested earlier this
year that he might not be up
for voting for a trump nominee in the
final year of his term
so he's sort of we don't know mitt
romney would be the other one because
romney of course voted in favor of
impeachment and he's a big i like to be
seen as genteel and civil kind of guy
even though he was
absolutely obliterated by a less than
genteel
obama biden campaign in 2012
but there was a rumor going around on
friday that he was already moving away
from voting for the nominee
and uh and then his spokesperson came
out and said no that's not true
so right now it appears that um
the right now it appears that there will
be enough republican votes although
again this thing is on a nice edge
wouldn't be if alabama republicans
hadn't nominated roy moore but that's
another story
so the way that the media are trying to
spin this is republicans are violating
norms
yes that's correct democrats are
threatening to impeach they're
threatening to
pack the supreme court add states kill
the filibuster four
separate things that violate every
institutional norm including norms that
have been in place for about 150 years
and um and republicans for performing
their exact article one functions
are apparently violating a
constitutional norm now the way
that the democrats are trying to claim
that republicans are violating the norm
is of course because republicans did not
bring up
merica garland for a vote in 2016.
now there are a couple things to be said
about this one i'm of the opinion and
you should never vote for as i said
never vote for a justice who is going to
pervert the constitution which means i
would have voted against sotomayor i
would have voted against kagan hell i
would have voted against john roberts
i mean the fact is that unless you have
a proven track record of voting
constitutionally
in court cases i would not vote for you
under any circumstance i don't care
whether it's year one i don't care
care whether it is your seven it is your
absolute constitutional duty not to vote
for justices you know will pervert the
constitution out of some out of some
weird perception of keeping order in the
senate that's not how any of this works
but
there was this norm for many years that
nominees would pass with flying colors
so for example
ruth bader ginsburg was confirmed with
an extraordinary majority
right ginsburg originally confirmed
by the senate with i believe was it 99
votes something like that
she she was she was confirmed by an
overwhelming vote and
96 to three 96 to three she was
confirmed which is absurd i mean she was
she was a now lawyer right she was for
the national organization of women
obviously very far to the left but there
was still this sort of
weird hangover from the 40s 50s 60s
where as long as the person wasn't
obviously judicially unqualified you
were going to vote for them no matter
what
that broke during the board carryings
and then it broke again during the
thomas hearings and then it seriously
broke during the kavanaugh hearings when
democrats took a very well-qualified
jurist no matter what you think his
ideology is and suggested he was a
rapist
at that point republicans were like
we're out right we're done here
now this thing's been openly partisan
for quite a while every time bush
nominated someone it was a far narrower
vote alito was a pretty narrow vote
roberts was a fairly narrow vote
actually speaking of just broader votes
okay but bottom line is this mcconnell
in 2016 said if the parties are
controlled if the chambers aren't
controlled by different parties
we have no obligation to bring the
person up for a vote in the final year
of an election the idea being once we
get past the election if it's if it's
hillary then we will confirm merrick
garland
now i always again i always thought that
was stupid i thought it was too clever
by half he should have just said we're
not confirming anybody that we don't
like
he could have just done that he didn't
do that okay so he got too clever
because he got too clever now democrats
are trying to suggest that it's
hypocrisy
it is worth noting that it's hypocrisy
in the other direction as well i know
everybody's ignoring this but it is
hypocrisy in the other direction as well
here's every democrat under the sun in
2016 saying that merrick garland's seat
should be filled apparently by a
republican senate who disagrees with the
nominee
the blockade on filling a naturally
occurring vacancy
in my view is harmful to the
independence of the article 3 branch
you cannot keep a seat on the supreme
court
which represents all of us you cannot
keep it vacant
against the constitution do pretty much
everything they can
to avoid acknowledging the legitimacy of
our democratically
elected president the american people
expecting the president's nominee
to be given a fair hearing and a timely
vote in the senate
every day that goes by without a ninth
justice is another day the americans
people's
business is not getting done so every
democrat flipped right every democrat
flipped so they're saying republicans
flipped on this the only difference is
that republicans were in the majority
both times so they said we don't have to
vote on the democrat and we will vote on
the person we like
that is not an unprincipled stand that
is a perfectly principled stand badly
articulated
in 2016. so you end up with questions
like this from chris wallace to tom
cotton the senator from arkansas
i really don't think there is any
hypocrisy at all
in saying we need to give voters because
i mean you can parse the 2014 election
the 2018 election any way you want
but you stated a pretty firm principle
in 2016 about merrick garland
it's wrong to deny voters a chance to
weigh in you don't see any hypocrisy
between that position then and this
position now
chris the senate majority is performing
our constitutional duty and fulfilling
the mandate that the voter
voters gave us okay bottom line is this
there was never any principle that
shouldn't have been any principle about
the last year
of a presidency that's silly again 29
people have been nominated
in that time when the party
of the senate is shared with the party
of the presidency then the person
ends up being confirmed when not
generally not right it is indeed
that simple now that's not stopping the
democrats from lying about the principle
right so barack obama put out a little
statement always too long because word
counts and barack obama
have never met but he wrote a basic
principle of the law and of everyday
fairness is that we apply rules with
consistency and not based on what's
convenient or advantageous in the moment
i'm sorry barack obama talking about
applying rules fairly
and not in advantageous ways from
captain pen and a phone over here from
captain let me drone an american citizen
while declaring a war in libya without
congressional approval
neutral principles barack obama come on
don't make me laugh the rule of law the
legitimacy of our courts the fundamental
workings of our democracy all depend on
that basic principle also we should get
rid of the filibuster add
states destroy the integrity of the
supreme court and
maybe just maybe you know basically do
what i want when i'm president of the
united states at all times regardless of
the politically neutral principle
i'm sorry so i heard from some
conservatives over the weekend
well before the weekend because uh it
was friday afternoon i heard from some
conservatives and they were saying
listen if we want the cons the country
to hold together then
there needs to be some sort of
compromise here if we want the country
to hold together there needs to be a
compromise
and the compromise needs to be that the
republicans back off of this and
democrats back off of their threats
because you know we have two sides they
disagree on everything and
if we want them not to pack the court if
we want them not to add states
and i said okay so what is the guarantee
they don't do that anyway considering
they've been talking about it for a long
time where is the trust there's no trust
that they're not gonna do it the fact
they're even making that threat
betrays the lack of trust i mean
this is this a peace deal or is this a
terrorist deal
you don't concede i've said this is the
third time i've said it on show it's
true you don't concede to political
terrorists they're threatening to
fundamentally
burn down the system if they do not get
what they want here you cannot concede
to that in fact it makes it more
important than ever
that you fulfill the constitutional
mandate and fill the seat fill
the damn seat fill it right now do not
wait fill it this week
force the democrats to hold hearings on
amy coney barrett or whoever else donald
trump
picks so joe biden is trying to walk it
back right joe biden
this has some real electoral
implications what's happening right now
so the democrats are stuck a little bit
between a rock and a hard place
like nobody knows how this is going to
break poll wise right it throws a hand
grenade in the middle of the election no
question
there are serious electoral implications
to this if democrats go too far
if democrats either try to bork amy
coney barrett a
catholic mother of seven from indiana
with very
well-qualified resume if they try to
bork her
or if they threaten that they are going
to add states to the country if they
threaten they're going to pack the
supreme court
if they threaten to impeach if they go
wild here
that puts joe biden's campaign in danger
the reason it puts joe biden's campaign
in danger is because joe biden was
supposed to be a breath
that was joe biden's candidacy he was
yes i'm old yes i'm daughter and yes i'm
barely coherent but that's the pitch
that's not the bug that's the feature
right i'm basically i'm not even alive
that's why you should vote for me
because this has been crazy right i mean
it's been four years
of constant non-stop tweeting and stress
and crazy elect joe biden this
walking corpse over here and you can
finally take a breath because i mean
really is anything going to get done
with this daughtering old guy over there
kind of like walking around eating a
scramble wait
probably not right that was the pitch
and it was a good pitch right that is a
good pitch i've said for years that was
going to be the democrats best pitch was
a return
a return to normalcy everything will go
back to normal
everybody can breathe for the first time
in years
okay that pitch completely disappears
the moment the entire democratic party
infrastructure
threatens to destroy every institutional
norm of the system
if the democrats now say that if joe
biden is president we are adding two
states and four democratic senators
permanently shifting the balance of
power in the united states senate
if the democrats say we are going to add
four supreme court justices with
lifetime tenure
which means that if a republican ever
gains power they have to pack the court
so we end up with
29 members of the supreme court and if
if not then democrats have been gamed
the system
if democrats say we're going to kill the
filibuster and ram through whatever we
damn raw please with a pac supreme court
to greenlight it
breaking the system in every way right
because no state
is going to abide by that again if you
are texas or mississippi or georgia or
florida are you going to sit around
and listen to a federal government with
51 votes
no filibuster greenlit by a packed
supreme court
tell you that constitutional norms no
longer exist and they can pass whatever
they damned well please
okay this is no longer a campaign
running for return to normalcy
this is a campaign running for a
complete remaking of the american
government
toward a direction that nobody has
consented to
and joe biden knows this right joe biden
knows that the more democrats fulminate
over this
the more they look radical the more they
look scary it becomes a referendum on
what the democrats will do
not on donald trump's weirdness because
here's the thing what donald trump's
doing right now is perfectly normal
every single president who has ever
encountered a supreme court opening has
nominated a human to fill that opening
every single one so donald trump is
right now doing the most normal thing he
has ever done in his presidency
donald trump is being extremely normal i
know sentence i never thought i would
say what he's doing right now is the
most
normal thing he has ever done in his
entire presidency
bar none a seat has been opened he is
filling the seat
democrats are now the party of
radicalism democrats are now the party
of not normal
it is not normal to threaten to impeach
somebody just to hold up the senate
process
it is not normal to say that with 51
votes you're going to pass whatever
legislation you want including
full states with their own sets of
senators that is not normal
you don't get to claim donald trump
donald trump is a threat to america's
core institutions while simultaneously
threatening to violate
every single norm and completely change
the structure of the balance of power
and the institutions themselves you
can't do that
you know who knows that as joe biden so
joe biden is scared
and so what joe biden is saying is we
need to de-escalate so joe biden is not
actually willing
to make these threats the reason he's
not willing to make the threats is the
minute he does this becomes a referendum
on biden not a referendum on trump
so biden's smart enough to know that
right he recognizes that and so instead
he's over here on the side saying we
need to de-escalate guys
we really need to de-escalate he's going
to try and and with the media
turn this into a referendum on the
republicans being mean to merrick
garland in 2016 which no one cares about
or remembers
i mean seriously like the number of
people in america who are like deeply
mourning for america garland
i remember his name very few other
americans do but he's going to try and
turn this into trump being not normal
that's a very difficult pitch
what he really has to protect himself
from here is the left flank of his party
which is now the mainstream flank of his
party we are beginning to see the
conflict break out into the open
between the kamala harris wing of the
party and the joe biden winning the
party
remember if trump nominates somebody
which he will and if that person has
hearings which they will
kamala harris is going to be there
trying to slander that supreme court
nominee in the same way she tried to
slander brett kavanaugh that's gonna be
real bad for biden
so biden for the first time is looking
kind of vulnerable up there and you can
tell he gave the speech yesterday
in which you can tell he doesn't know
which way to go he's kind of like a
trapped rabbit here
here's joe biden yesterday anger and
anger sorrow and frustration the way
things are in this country now
politically
that's the cycle that republican
senators will continue to perpetuate
if they go down this dangerous path that
they put us on
we need to de-escalate not escalate
so i appeal to those few senate
republicans
the handful who really will decide what
happens
please follow your conscience okay so
everybody
needs to de-escalate by doing exactly
what we want because if we don't
de-escalate then we're going to blow
everything up
here's what joe biden could do right and
he won't here's what joe biden could do
what joe biden could do is he could
right now say to mitch mcconnell
here's the deal i pledge i pledge
right in public writing and he who'd
have to give some sort of guarantee that
makes
some sense i pledge we will not pack the
court
we will not do any of the world breaking
things i'm talking about
we will not kill the filibuster we will
not add stage we won't know any of that
if you hold the seat open joe biden
can't do that though right so that'd be
an easy giveaway for him but he can't do
that because his
his own party will kill him for doing
that remember they were talking about
this stuff
before the seat opened which means as
josh holmes former
press secretary for mitch mcconnell said
they already shot the hostage
they already made the threat it's too
late there is no trust that can be built
on the back of joe biden
nobody's going to trust that even if joe
biden guarantees personally that they're
not going to do any of these things
that they won't do any of those things
regardless of whether the republicans
fill the seat
there is no stepping back from the brink
here it's not a thing that is going to
happen
republicans must morally speaking move
forward that's putting aside all of the
impact that a supreme court justice will
do
including uh you know again i'm not a
person who believes deeply in the
generalized power of the supreme court i
think they tend to more green light
trends than they do
actually stand up for the constitution
but there will be edge cases where the
supreme court makes a difference and
preventing the left from gaining
complete
footholds in the supreme court that is a
real thing and i'm more interested in
having
another person on the supreme court to
not be wild leftist than i am
you know suggesting faith in the supreme
court
to implement the actual constitutional
principle with all of that said joe
biden has a problem here
his problem is very obvious he can't
appear radical his party is now
threatening extremely
radical things and republicans know this
which is why the two people who they are
talking about nominating are amy coney
barrett
on the one hand and a woman named
barbara lagoa on the other so amy coney
barrett is from indiana
she's a catholic on a personal level is
anti-abortion but
again that makes no sense and that makes
no difference in terms of her
constitutional
jurisprudence she has uh seven children
uh she happens to be a very attractive
candidate like she's very camera
friendly
trump first nominated her to the u.s
court of appeals for the seventh circuit
in 2017.
she previously taught at university of
notre dame for 15 years so she had no
previous judicial record to scrutinize
barrett wasn't a total novice to the
judicial system she clerked for justice
scalia
during her confirmation hearings she
said she would follow all supreme court
precedent without fail and would regard
roe vs wade as binding precedent
democrats then went completely
anti-religious on barrett
they said that um they quoted her saying
that a quote legal career is but a means
to an end and that end is building the
kingdom of god
well if you've ever met a religious
human being every single religious
person believes that whatever their
career is
is a means toward serving god that is
what it means to be a religious person
that doesn't mean that she's going to
start
writing new testament segments into
supreme court decisions
that's very very silly it is true that
in the past she has written
she doesn't believe the supreme court is
bound to bad precedent so she is going
to be a candidate
it will be difficult for democrats to
attack without looking petty and
ridiculous
the other candidate who they've been
looking at is barbara lagoa so she's
quickly risen to the top
of the list that is because she's a
cuban-american in florida which of
course is a swing state
her record is not particularly clear
because she doesn't have a long record
of judicial decisions
now listen i tend to be with josh halley
here i think every judicial nominee
should be asked
point blank are you going to overrule
roe if the answer is no you shouldn't be
nominated
democrats do this i don't see how
republicans should not except they don't
believe they'll be able to get away with
it
but barbara lagoa has has been now
elevated to the top
of the stack her 14-year tenure as a
state and federal judge presents
democrats with opportunities to
scrutinize her record says the
washington post
so she concurred this month in a federal
appeals court ruling that is expected to
keep 85 000 felons registered to vote in
florida
from casting ballots she repeatedly
sided with business when she was on the
florida high court she was nominated
by ron desantis and uh she has said that
she would faithfully apply precedence
when it came to roe
versus way roe versus wade people who
know her say that she is very pro-life
which again doesn't mean
anything when it comes to jurisprudence
it just means that she's personally
pro-life she's a mother of three
including a pair of twins
apparently she is quiet and collegial
with shrewd political instincts
she was also a member of the pro bono
legal team representing the miami
relatives of elian gonzalez the cuban
boy whose mother drowned while trying to
escape with him to the united states
and uh who was turned over to his father
in cuba by the clinton
administration so lagoa is uh
is you know obviously very friendly with
the federalist society
her husband uh paul huck is a godfather
of the federalist society in miami
apparently so they're these are the two
kind of top nominees both of them would
be difficult
for democrats to attack joe biden has to
know this
it's why joe biden has to be very
concerned about the democratic party
going too far here
he really should be it's a danger to his
election and frankly it's an injury to
the system because if the democrats go
too far you are going to start to see
the country break up you're going to see
states start to say the federal
government has lost all legitimacy
democrats got to be real careful here a
lot more careful than
than republicans in merely fulfilling
what everybody else figured which is
if trump appoints a replacement and the
republicans hold the senate
they get to confirm him alright we'll be
back here later today with two
additional hours of content a lot i
didn't get to including
the ridiculousness of the emmys plus
nicole hannah jones deleting her entire
twitter history
the 1619 project lady who says we can't
whitewash history completely whitewashed
her own
twitter history yet over the weekend
we'll talk about that a little bit later
on otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wiedowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina
hair and makeup is by nico geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clayton